good morning Hank it's Friday Esther
Earl the nerdfighter who inspired a lot
of nerdfighters recent worldsuck
decreasing projects died earlier this
week she was 16 Esther was a great
friend to many people in nerdfighteria
and a great friend to me personally and
for a long time she has been a huge part
of the life of the nerdfighter community
and our community in turn was a huge
part of her life her best friends were
nerdfighters here you can see her
nerdfighter friends giving her a
scrapbook that includes notes and
drawings from hundreds of nerdfighters
Haigh Esther was an amazing kid she was
astonishingly empathetic she was really
thoughtful she's very funny but she
wasn't an angel or a model of perfection
or anything she was a person she was a
teenager she answered formspring
questions like do you have names for
your butt cheeks with not as of yet but
that is a good idea but she also wrote
tweets like words aren't overwhelming me
they're just going into my brain and I
contemplate them and then I decide I
don't need them so I throw them away it
was with Esther that the nerdfighter
community came together and helped the
Harry Potter Alliance win $250,000 and
Hank it was because of Esther that on
Esther day I told you that I love you
which I do although I don't want to talk
about it and even though Esther has died
we will continue to do projects with her
because it will be when we work to
decrease worldsuck and when we show our
love for others that Esther will be with
us most so Hank as you know before I
wrote books I worked as a chaplain at a
Children's Hospital and when I was there
my supervisor always used to tell me
John don't just do something stand there
we all want to do something to mitigate
the pain of loss or to turn grief into
something positive to find a silver
lining in the cloud but I believe there
is real value in just standing there
being still being sad bearing witness to
Esther's life and allowing ourselves to
be transformed by it
Esther talked to me about that when I
saw her a couple months ago in Boston
she talked about how she believes that
the Dead live on in the memory and the
lives of those they have touched but
there is something in this case that we
can do if you're so inclined you can
give to the Friends of Esther fund a
fund that goes directly to her family to
help them deal with the many expenses
that were incurred
during her care there's a link in the
doobly-doo to give there's also links to
Esther's Twitter account enter her
YouTube accounts she was vlogging
throughout much of the last month and
her vlogs are hilarious and charming and
very touching
so Hankel on Monday vlogbrothers videos
will again start looking vlog brother II
and I will do my punishment on Wednesday
by the way thanks to everyone who
participated in the birthday video that
was just that's gah but we will continue
to be inspired to do big things to make
the world suck less with Esther Esther
means star and her friends had a
bracelet printed up that reads this star
won't go out and it won't we won't let
it Hank I'll see you Monday one quick
story about Esther so we were all
answering questions that were written on
a soccer ball and the question Esther
got was what would you tell your younger
self if you could go back in time and
speak to her and first she was like but
then she did answer the question and her
answer is I think a nice reminder to all
of us maybe I would say that your family
is like important okay okay Esther my
friend Godspeed